- [Voiceover] So many people have
a preconceived notion
of what I am capable of
just at first sight.
When I do my thing and they see it
and they're like whoa.
(hip hop music)
I love giving that shock and ah feeling.
It's just like, so you
think I can only do this
but I'm going to show you
I can do so much more.
My name is Dexter Mayfield
and I am a plus-size male
model and professional dancer
for about eight years now, oh my goodness.
The journey has been long.
It has been hard being a bigger person.
There's not as many opportunities
but at the same time there's
so many opportunities
that you would never expect.
I am so happy with this.
So I've been able to
dance for Jennifer Lopez
for her “Papi” music video,
Sara Bareilles for her “Brave” music video.
I was actually able to walk the runway
as a plus-size model for Marco
Marco at L.A. Fashion Week
and that has been an eye
opening experience for me.
I was never actually trained
professionally as a dancer.
I never expected to be
a professional dancer
given my body type.
Being a gay black man
in America is not easy,
especially being a big
gay black man in America,
and it took me awhile to really
find that love for myself, my true self.
Whenever we think of bigger men
we view them as something to
laugh at and we're not that.
We love our bodies as
well and we are sexy too.
Like, I can't say that
enough, like, we are sexy too.
At the end of the day,
I just wanna be seen as
someone who
deserves this,
as someone who is capable,
not just seen as just
an overweight person,
not just seen as a black actor, dancer,
not seen as whatever
that first impression is.
I just wanna be seen as
someone who is talented enough
for this job.
(inspiring music)